this is a production of Cornell
University thank you so much Don for
such a kind introduction and thank you
so much everyone for coming here today I
know it's such a high demanding labor in
the field right now and but thanks to
the rayon that you can get the other
people to you so the main the main goal
of my research is only one thing it was
trying to breed switchgrass to be
resistant to diseases caused by by Paris
or I see so the topic here that I put is
pretty simple that does the switch grass
versus the by Perez or I see which is a
fungal pathogen a challenge in breeding
for resistant I know that I have been
presenting you about switchgrass
for so many years and so many times now
but you may think that switch pad is
still out of your out of your circle
it's just out of your everyday life but
actually it's not because the first
picture this is a switchgrass that I was
taking the tick was taking this picture
right in front of corneal health center
or can it and he was planted in the
slope like right in front of that so
sushma has been used for preventing the
soil erosion pretty well in this case
and also the second pictures can you
guess where is this one it's in Stuart
Park one of your favorite place in
Ithaca actually we have yeah so it was
planted in just the side of the road so
switchback has been used for the for the
landscape decoration quite some time but
actually Swiss grass has been introduced
as a forest purpose crop but in 2000
square has been introduced as one of the
biomass candidate by Department of
Energy as a biomass crop because of its
high you and it's also good in terms of
greenhouse gas image and capacity right
here it's also very well it's a native
grass to North America and it's very
well adapted across the latitude so it's
separated into a plan switchgrass and
lowland switchgrass so
this the next victor is a comparison
between the upland and lowlands to
express so this sir on your left-hand
side is a upland and on your right-hand
side it's a lowland so normally a plan
is well adapted to the cold wind like ko
winter out like right down around here
but the lowland is well adapted into
like the higher moisture area and also
provided more you another different is
the deploy be level a different a that
upland is normally octopi and lowland is
normally thattaboy
but if you just one like the just just a
general idea if you walked in the field
so you can separate it by just the
colors of it because the lowland type is
normally bluish green and based on these
difference it's also a difference in
terms of the resistance also
surprisingly after domestication in 1940
nineteen seven seventy there there are
only about 1700 application of
switchgrass and litter of them just only
28 of them is related to disease even
though and John mentioned that there's a
lots of diseases in switchgrass such as
rust and track nose and of course the
the deceased bye-bye for its Ric and
let's get back to our basic and
pathology triangle that to confer the
resistant of acceptability the horse
which is switched grass that I already
introduced to you was attacked by a
pathogen and in this case is by priests
or I see vibrates or I see is an ESCO
mices fungus that it's it's a necrotic
nickel copic pathogen and to present in
general if we want to emphasize the
importance of the disease we always put
the worst case scenario and of course
which pass I'm sorry of a course by
forests of or I see also has the worst
case of bees disease that it killed 2 to
3 million people in India during the
Bengal famine in 1943
and these because this can cause the
disease in rice and this pathogen also
cost the city in switchgrass also it can
cause two diseases
first is by three C drugs as the name
suggested it reduce the termination of
the seeds but even though that seeds can
germinate this pathogen can infect the
shoot and the root of that of the seeds
also and it can these are the pictures
of the of the hyphy and the corn idea
which is a sexual sport of this pathogen
on the seat surface another disease is
by prairie leaf spot that it cost the
necrotic lesions on the leaves like this
that can reduce the you up to fifty
percent and that's a huge amount if we
consider to you used to use switchgrass
for biomass production in terms of
management of the disease we need to
understand the lifecycle of the pathogen
before we make any decision which way
we're gonna manage the disease and
vibrates or I see it's the seed and so I
borne pathogen that the first inoculum
of the disease is from the seeds that it
was introduced to the few and after that
the high field of these pathogen can
grow into the soil and leaf and
overwintering within the within the crop
residue in the field and after that this
it can spray except spread the the
quantity of Spore into the mature plant
and cause the leaf the leaf lesion the
last angle of this triangle is
environment what is the best environment
for for this pathogen to cause the
disease in switchgrass and of course
it's here in New York with the with the
prolong high humidity and high
temperature during summer this is the
perfect home for these disease that's
why I like that's why I'm what I I work
with this disease and why I picked the
breeding
management method over other approaches
that okay if it's a fungal disease why
don't we just spray spray at the front
aside to the few or fumaça the soy as it
the soy borne pathogen of course you can
do that but it's pricey right because we
consider we we consider consider using
switchgrass for biomass production and
we try to reduce the input as much as I
can as we can
another solution is because it is seed
borne pathogen why don't we just
just soak the seed with the fungus I
even though I show you that there's a
fungal this fungus can grow on the seat
surface but these also has been proof
that it's in there can be with inside
the seed tissue so this may not be an
option another one is just the
cultivation practice normally like we
can like plow the soy to disrupt the to
disrupt the life cycle of these disease
but because switchgrass is a perennial
crop so this this is not an option
another another another concern about
these switchgrass is the target
environment for switchgrass it's in
martin öhlin such as to reclaim my area
that we try to reduce the competition
between food and and oil and crops who
grow in life in a good land so this is
the target environment here that it has
low nutrient high i heavy metal and high
acidity that's the worst place to live
to plant switchgrass but that's a place
that that we picked for finding them so
and that's that's why i pick the method
of breeding to manage these disease so
the content today i already introduced
you the background of the hosts which
pass the pathogen of the vibrates or IC
and to make a selection I set up the
screening method first let's move into
the first one so four by four feet broad
I basically just soak the seat with the
inoculum and come with the inoculum and
compare with the seat with just a
control one
so I set up the screening method based
on this height based on these the
variation and I found that Adweek these
are the like and I found that the the
first week shows the highest germination
but that is not the that is not the day
that I should collect the data because
do you remember that these pathogen can
infect the shoot and the root of the of
the new leader early germinated seeds so
that's can drop the germination during
the week three here so I picked a week
for two evil evil at least these disease
and to scratch its screen this the
resistant with this condition another
disease is the Buried leaf spot so I
have to option here like to screen in
seedlings or to screen in mature plants
I picked the seedlings one because I can
handle it in greenhouse like any time of
the year and I also can increase the
number or num increase the replicates as
many as I want so I used at least a
thousand or two thousand per cycle for
screening that it would take like a lot
of land to produce in the in the field
for mature plants so the basic method
for screening this is to I screen the
resistant to vibrate leaf spot in four
weeks all settings I sprayed it cover
with a clear plastic bag for 24 hours
delays it and and I set up and I did you
mean the condition when I'm gonna
evaluate the disease and what
concentration I use so these are the
score that I've that I used to evaluate
the disease resistant from 0% to 100% as
like 100 the coper the whole leaf so I
have two options to just just evaluate
at only one day or add as a percent leaf
coverage by their lesions or I can use
the area under this is progress curb
along with from day one to day ten and I
found that there's a very high
correlation between the the air
the one day at this event to that 10
days Valu at Rao point 9 so I so the
screening method will be just evaluate
at fights at the day 7 only and so I
used this criteria and I used the
highest concentration to screen this to
increase the intensity that you have to
survive from this and you'll be the best
and do and at this point I I was
wondering like if the seat that was
inoculated before that can survive from
those pathogen can also increase the it
resistant when they grow up as resist as
the seedlings so but I couldn't but
based on that experiment I found that
there's no correlation between the
resistant of these two to DC these two
disease so based on this no correlation
I use this no correlation to setup I use
this information to set up the breeding
scheme and let's move into the third one
that I make the actual selection based
on these resistance so basically I use a
recurrent phenotypic selection for two
cycles of selection and based on the
fact that beast too resistant has no
correlation I separated into into
resistant by vibrated secret and vibrate
leaf spot I made for a two cycle top
selection and at the end of cycle to I
taste a reciprocal taste between that
the one that selected for vibration rods
also got like Osprey by the pipe
got spray when it was in seedlings also
and because shelter and Kevin Rock show
pretty well adapted to New York and hide
you in New York State I pick I make a
selection based on these two population
which is a plan switchgrass I produce
just hop ship seats in greenhouse and in
few nursery
I also producer so I made a selection
for the caiman drop and shelter right
which is an upland type so I can produce
it interview easily but I also produce
to have success of the callow in in the
greenhouse
also because hello is a so I used hello
as a lowland representative in this case
to to have an idea like what is the
resistant in their lowland should be and
normally when we make a selection it's
it's good to know like good to know how
horrible it the trade is that's why I I
evaluate her to be based on the
individual and based on the hops it and
the results showing that the for the
resistant to buy for a seed brought the
kelo kelo switch past showing like
pretty pretty high with moderate to high
fertility at point five and the one that
I made an actual selection which is a
cabin drop it's showing at point three
which is also moderate heritability that
when you get this number before you make
the selection we have you had hope that
you can get some gain from this
selection and of course I make some gain
from this election this graph represent
this the y-axis represent the percent
germination and each pair of the of the
Bhakra represent each cycle of selection
on your left hand side is the wrist
respond from the cap in rock and your
right hand side is a shelter let's see
at at the Kim Rockford Kevin rock first
that you remember that I got moderate
heritability so I should have some
progress here the the the yellow bar is
the control because control seed and the
blue bar is the inoculated seeds as you
can see here for the base cycle the
cycle zero that never be selected before
they say this is significantly different
between control and the inoculated one
that the inoculated one has a reduction
in the germination and the
the difference between the control and
inoculated ones do persist in psycho
psycho one also but these differences
between the control and the treatment
one was reducing into non significantly
different in within psycho psycho psycho
two which is good that okay you get the
good result out of this this similar
trend is also happening with the shelter
that the the best populations do have
was significantly different between the
control and the treatment one but we
leave just one cycle of selection that
gap was significantly different at all
here and based on this gap between the
control and inoculated one I plot this
this gap as a percent termination
reduction the lower the bar the more
resistant disease as you see here the
trend is very obvious that from psycho
zero so castle cycle two in Kevin Rock
its drop like this which means that it's
increased the resistant obviously the
similar trend also happen in shelter two
that is dropped but it has a variation
here but it's already like difference
and the base population in this case
based on this huge improvement on
percent germination reduction the
percent genetic gains rate between cycle
zero and cycle to cycle zero and say go
to here it's over a hundred percent but
it's around sixty percent per cycle of
selection and it's also around fifty
percent per cycle of selection in
shelter also and based on these percent
genetic gains I can calculate the
liability heritability which is to
realize its ability in case in this case
of the German of the binary trade like
this that it's got y2 here and point
three here which is acceptable what the
rate heritability so as a plant breeder
I'm so proud of this result that okay I
got something out of this but what about
do you remember another disease they
vibrate leaf spot that is like so I got
this resolved so I hope I get something
from that so I went to the to the
similar step to first evaluate the hurt
beauty of that resistant to vibrate leaf
spot and it this is the result
this is like am I dreaming
is it zero zero not hurt a bit are you
serious like I spent like three years on
this and it's zero so I didn't keep up
that time so at that time the first
evaluation of the estimate of the her to
be its to me it was being was done in
seven trays with with three replicates
so I try to like change the inoculation
method from just the health way to the
airbrush that can produce more
consistence more drop of the inoculum
that can firmly attached to the leaf
well I tried everything I try to and I
also try to fit just from 125 hops a
protein ease across seven trace I fit it
into just one tray and just discard like
most of them just use 44 hop zip of that
and I try like a lots of combination up
here and it's been almost a year on this
and Wow all of them 0 or non significant
let's just grade that is very good news
for you
so after and this is like but I didn't
trust the result from these fertility
estimate because come on that's just the
estimate and what's up what about if I
just just stoppin to make the risk to
make selection based on these techniques
and this is the result of my
stubbornness but but none of them like
each thing none of them looks the same
are they copying the result ish none of
them making any see any progress out of
this election so what's wrong with that
I still don't know so I try to make the
case cross like to go back to this the
newer basic genetics class to go back to
your first step to make a test cross I
make a cross of the resistant by
resistant resistant by susceptible
acceptable by resistant and resistant by
resistance as
as the bid from the basic tech book
textbook and I found that all of them
like these are the histogram of the
progeny of each cross the resistant
resistant resistance acceptable and each
cross of yet the the top here is a cape
in rock protein II and out of and the
lower here is a shelter progenies and
all of this graph rep
nomally distributed with just unimodal
pattern like there's no multiple like
the kids in this segregation in this
histogram so i can conclude that these
resistant might be this resistance
should be controlled by multiple alleles
with the small effects of each alleles
and because i there's no significant
difference between the reciprocal cross
i can conclude that there's no ii linked
in here it's an inheritance here and
also this only like even like when i try
to compare between this group across
only the resistant by resistant is
differently different from the
succeptible base acceptable which is not
which is this this this different is
expected but I have also expected that
the the one that got the resistant in
the cross leg resistant by susceptible
and resistant bus susceptible resistance
should be different from the subsets
above acceptable also but it didn't show
that way so in the conclusion for from
these selection based on the different
trend in the in the selection that the
top bar is a selection it's a screening
for the vibrate seat rock and the lower
bar lower result is a resistant to by
free this leaf spot and you see like
there's no trend here like flat trend
here and in the resistant to vibrate sit
right that's a huge trend here they it
reduce here the the light blue bar here
representing the population that was
selected for vibrate leaf spot so
there's a reduction here there's no
significantly different between the
between beast with with the base
population so I make up at this point I
made significant progress in the
resistant to back rate citron but I
didn't make any progress in the
batteries leaf spot but that's that's
not the that's not all the bad news
because do you remember the back the the
previously that I mentioned that bcc's
was primary was inoculated firstly in
the seeds
that's the seeds carry the pathogen into
the field at the first so this at least
good news that I can reduce the primary
inoculation to the few at the beginning
that its overall gonna reduce the
incidence of vibrate leaf spot in the
field in the later year and what's odd
the explanation of the of the of the no
progress in resistant to bacterial leaf
spot there's a there's a bunch of them
there may be the low natural pressure of
these or this is a complex trait that
it's control like basis and I work with
the octopi switchgrass and to psych hold
up selection may not be enough to push
these to be more resistant or the worst
case is there might not be the resistant
in this population that I'm working with
so here is a conclusion for the
prettiest part of my research and be
still confirm that there's no
correlation between these two resistant
and this can give the idea that in
future we can make a selection based on
these two traits like if like separately
so but I at this point of of my result I
was at my fourth year already
so so if you add my shoes in my shoes so
you know how it's you but I didn't feel
discouraged actually but but but I try
to like I try to learn what's what's
wrong with a resistant to by three leaf
spot and because even though these
disease these beliefs what it's it's one
of the major disease in rice but there
are only four publications about
the resistance in the rice population
which is quite I don't know what what
was wrong with this but there's only
four papers of that but the reason the
most recent paper was identified was
trying to identify the resistant in
three chromosome and they used the they
used snips they can confirm the 13 snips
marker that linked to the resistant
region here but they're just in that
paper data stop there so I try to dig a
little bit deeper that in that paper in
that research they used the NIA so tunic
lie between the indica and the
temperature Monica and and based on that
like I I just want to know that what are
the what are the resistant genes that
link to these markers so the linkage
disequilibrium in indica is around 100
KB and the LD for the temperature punica
is 200 Kb
so I just used the 200 k be read 200 KB
linkage disequilibrium here to just
satisfy that what are the genes that
link to these 13 snips marker so I just
search it in the phyto so database and I
found that there are two hundred seventy
eight genes that linked to these 13
markers and half of them are annotated
and other half is not and interestingly
most of the frequent heat that was
showing to me including the leucine-rich
repeat family protein and nucleotide
binding lives in which repeat here of
like showing the most out of out of 270
h1 and these two proteins and well known
for its its its function as a are teen
because it's detecting the pathogen
another most heat protein is the the
peroxidase precursor peroxidase it's
quite important in terms of the
resistant or these pathogen to this
pathogen because this the vibrates or IC
is a neck wrote off so it used it used
the program sale days that
that related to real reactive oxygen
species in the in the mechanism of the
acceptability so this is important for
that the written it the reason is also
important in terms of the lignin
synthesis that it prevent the infection
for this disease the my B protein it's
very well known for its resistant
capacity that it responds to most biotic
and abiotic stress in general disease so
based on these two hundred eighty seven
genes I just put up all of the sequence
and blast back to so because this based
on the rice data so I pour out of these
gene sequence and blast back to the
switchgrass switchgrass database and I
found that the top 10 percent score of
those blast hit there's still like 1400
genes out of that so at least I have
some hope that there should be some
resistant genes in in switchgrass
population so at this point I try to
dissect the resistant 2 by 3 leaf spot
by using the genome-wide Association so
I went back to the first step that I
would not working with the seedlings
anymore it give me everything so I
worked with a mature plant that I've
I've got a chance to to evaluate this in
in a mature plan that was already a
genotype so the population that I use is
a shoosh grass not an association panel
that is consists of 66 population that
both both the commercialized cultivars
from switchgrass or or some of them are
also the natural collection of the
switchgrass and though from from those
population we plant five to six seeds
for each population into individual so
in total I have 470 19 and in 2000 2016
we planted in Ithaca and in in in
Phillipsburg in Pennsylvania for three
clones and just last year we was
suspended in in rocker so but but these
this data it's only from last year data
because
we have one year left so I was having
only one chance in two locations so at
this point at this point at with the 66
population in 479 I just want to the
goal is was was to screening tutors
identify what's the best candidate for
the resistant out of this population and
what because all of these has been
genotyped already what are the what are
the the the marker the snips marker that
links to potential resistant gene to the
by price or ice vibrating spot
so the so at first it's the easiest way
to evaluate the disease just walk
through fear right so I evaluate by just
using my eyes I evaluate with the score
from 0 to 5 in the field and we start
showing like this that each so I
represent these result in 66 population
each bar represents 66 population and
it's coded by the different eco type a
plan and lowland and this order based
and this power order based on the mean
from two locations and as you can see
here there's no like there's no similar
trend between the based on true mean
from two location with the mean from
just New York and mean from from
Pennsylvania and that's it's just that
showing me that it's a huge
environmental effects to the resistant
to vibrate leaf spot so I come up with
the so I try to evaluate I try to
eliminate those environmental effect by
just taking the leap sample back to the
back to the lab and and sprayed it and
inoculated did so I did into two si in
the leaf detachment assay and the leaf
is actually for the leaf it hashman si I
basically just cut to 5 centimeters so
first real I sprayed it 70 like over 7
days and you've elevated and also like
scan each leaf scan each leaf and use
image analysis to
like to detect the the deletion so you
may notice that like I use the disease
it's in the dot right a black dot but I
like alright so I can based on these
pictures I can extract lots of data out
of that it's just a black dog or just
overall necrosis but in this in this one
I show you the overall necrosis that
showing and that we saw it's pretty high
correlated with my eye data eyes
evaluation but I know that's not a good
like candidate from the result that I
give you like non significant we saw
previously another evaluation that I did
was using the leaf teas essay that I
just call the leaf into - yeah like one
centimeters and put in the water and
take pictures of that and using
nationalise image j to extract each leaf
circle and evaluate like the similar
things also and that's a high
correlation at point seven with like
coil it with my eyes result and based on
these i can evaluate all right so the so
i evaluate a brush and hurt ability and
this time it's showing very high boston
horrific hurt ability at point seven
point five keep skip this one and point
three and five
i skip this one because you remember
that there's a huge environment so
effect here that you you have the high
high heritability in each location but
when you combine consider two location
where are you so that's the koi so so
even though I have this high cool high
fertility from each evaluation
approaches but when I tried but when I
try to just rank it by the public by the
DTI ia is the result from the dish
please and detached leaf with the image
analysis one so I rank this by based on
the tree they have leaf results and you
see the let's do like no no trend with
this leaf and no trend with the mean of
two locations from two locations
and this and this showing that like
there's no correlation even with the the
within the risk evaluation for the
resistant to by priya leaf spot there's
no correlation between that like this
high correlation is between the my eyes
and the bitchin and beyond the the
resistant to bacterial leaf spot there's
also like no correlation with other by
by biomass rates as the mineral content
the digestibility the cell wall
concentration or the the ethanol yield
i'm from the dry biomass so based on the
fact that there's no correlation based
on this i the way that I fit the G was I
was trying to just fit it as by itself
by its single trait or just a
combination of the like plots of traits
and I also include the the third the
first three principal component that can
explain around 15 percent variation in
this population and also use a kinship
metrics as a random effects and the Audi
the linkage disequilibrium that if it's
that give the idea how how how why this
is the gene the link to the the the
marker that I used and in this
population is 20 kilo base pair so as I
mentioned earlier that the way that I
fit g was is I was trying to just fit
the single trait of itself and the
combination of many traits there from
the from the detach Lee from the Beasley
from the EU and everything and more than
90 percent of of my tea was non
significant non significant kicked and
like or or even though or some of them
just like give me the very very
unreliable QQ plot that some of them
left the panel too early some of them
just like smoothie normal they didn't
show me the significant but but some
more
you show me like some home let's do
something in my research so I also based
on because I have like 479 population I
subset in those 400 sets every night you
know types into like many many groups
the the first one is just I used like
the whole thing with the combination of
the detach leaf and this leaf and the
maximum in New York State I used maximum
the value from the few evaluation which
is the most severe in the field because
none of the black or none of the mean
from the few evaluation show me the
significant results of the team of the
device at all and I used the maximum
because Washington in in and pathology
suggested me to do this that hey you
don't need to think as a plant breeder
or a time you need to think as a hunter
ecology sometime that if you have the
plants in the same field that you have
three replicates one of them show no
symptom one of them show the words why
don't you just pick the worst one like
they consider that's the worst case so
that's why I consider using the maximum
value and it's showing showing something
here that some significant peak here is
related to antioxidant protein which is
very good in terms of the resistant to
vibrate vibrate leaves more my be which
is related to the bio bio biotic and
abiotic stress the the disc and this one
the ring finger this is related to
program so date the and DST the GU da
hai own s transferase it's also related
to the antioxidant activities the the
most important piece here is this one I
know that it's not like the Mike G was
didn't provide like the very Manhattan
part like the significant P like that
but these showing me the most
interesting one because the cytochrome
p450 is the only one only one key that
overlap with the blast result that I got
from rice that I used the
the infirm rise and a blast back to the
to the switchgrass and this is the only
one that overlap with that data and the
importance of this by the compy 450 450
it's it's synthesized for four
triterpene triterpene is also well known
for like the antifungal activities such
the most well known triterpene is a
venison in oat that is also like also
resistant to act as a antifungal
activities - and now the subset is the
data ploy in this switchgrass so I fit
this so the data ploy showing the only
devices showing the significant from the
data place update if the maximum value
in the few in New York State and is
showing that it links with the program
so did protein and also the protein that
induced in their cross is one here
another subset is the subset of the
lowland that it also shows that the
antifungal proteins here and here it's
linked with in this peak linked with the
nucleotide binding SIA use in which
repeat protein which is also well known
for acting as an r RG r protein that
detector detects a pathogen so for the a
plant it's just showing only one piece
here that link to BW 40 even though
there's no like study like directly
directly say that this is like related
to any plant disease but it's also but
this is very important for a
biosynthesis for my beef protein which
is also linked to the the and stress and
base
on this although like as you as you know
that like I have most of my Tevas non
significantly different non-secure none
like didn't give me a significant result
but the the significant she was that I
have here there's no overlap Peaks out
of this population at all which is it's
not it's not an ideal result but at
least it's better than just zero
heritability and non non progress of
from the selection and there's a showing
up like the key which that they're
showing up that beast and when I
compared I consider over all of these
give us this the showing up the the key
genes that link that link to these
markers that is reasonably research that
can convert resistant to the capacitor
to this disease resistant to this
disease but it's still missing some
genes that I expect to see like dilatant
that linked that is linked to the
Dyckman synthesis the peroxidase ml all
like proteins and the only only fits in
on chromosome B from the 479 here it's
linked with the blast results from
previous from the rice and based on
these let's get back to the goal for the
study of this that the first goal is
trying to identify the most resistant
genotypes or population in this in this
66 population but as you remember that
this like none of the phenotypic
approaches here has like has correlation
between each other that's why I like I
can I cannot make the conclusive
decision that okay this one is the best
out of all of them in all hi Tyria but
if I need to if I need to put people if
I need to pick the most the best one
right now
I will pick SW 805 because it's always
on the top top 10 percent of this
population
and and the multitrack she was here
really helps me to review some of the
some of the some of the slips marker
that is that is linked to the resistant
in reasonably so at this point it's the
end of my reading part that I try so
hard to breed to breed for these trades
and um and but don't forget that we
still can manage this disease by another
approaches and in this recent year
there's a trend to implement silicone to
to rise to be resistant to vibrate by
prairies leaf spot and it has been
proved that this silicon can can court
the Seidman sorry can cut the leaves to
prevent the the attacked of the
intrusion of this pathogen like
physically and also these silicon can
trigger the the defense mechanism
molecule such as such as Munich s just
like acid or salicylic acid lastly it's
quite surprising that it's they also
prove that the silicon can prevent the
take that taking over of the ethylene
production from from rice so I have and
based on these that's a star D to screen
the to screen to screen the gene in Kelo
switchgrass and they they found that
there there are at least two two key
genes in in translocating for silicon in
switchgrass LS I won and LSI to so based
on this knowledge I had some hope that
okay even though I didn't make any
progress from the selection I can make
progress from testifying silicon to
switchgrass and make it more resistant
here but there's a concern about the
appliance which silicon to switchgrass -
because Swiss grad was was aimed to use
for the biomass right so we basically
want to burned it or turn it into
ethanol
if you want to burned it this silicon
the highest silicon amount can I can
melt at five hundred or seven to seven
hundred degrees Celsius and clockers and
create the slack like this ten o'clock
the heating system so that's like the
implement of silicon into Swiss bed it's
also concerned too and these are the
just a basic idea of how many how much
how much silicon in the in the tissue of
this plant and you can see here like
Swiss quartz is already high higher than
Miscanthus which is also another biomass
crop too but it's still lower than dry
so maybe it's silicon may not hurt this
but but we should not a good side the
results show that there's no there's no
effect of the silicon amendment to the
to the resistant to either vcss I try to
to mix the silicon powder with the saw
and with the soy and find the fan fan
switchgrass there and taste the vibrates
it but there's a back release but there
there's no significant effect on that
even though like so the the the yellow
block yellow yellow bar here represent
the silicon one and the blue by is
control one even though it looks like
significantly different but when we
taste statically statistically it's not
like significant different and so okay
there may be like some saw a mixing
problem so I try to just water the
silicon solution to to them to and
there's no like no improvement between
between silicon and the control one so
at this point I think I'm cursed so
there's no improvement but there's quite
some explanation on these two that there
might be a low retention of piece of
this silicon in the I didn't use the so
I use a corny Opie like medium so there
may be low retention on that and like
there's no biological like for the
resistant to back release it got this
like watering silicon when it's seeds it
may not have any biological effects on
that lastly like this
that I use for screening for vibrate
leaf spot may not be like enough they
may not be appropriate for the silicon
to accumulate like the in the in the
tissue already but I need we need to
keep in mind that this result it's the
it's a greenhouse result so it cannot be
infer the effect of this silicon
amendment in the field so if anyone want
to try this
thank you welcome to continue this
research so overall for my research I
would like to conclude that as a plant
breeder I'm pretty proud of of the
improvement of the resistant to by free
seed brought that it's increased like
come on sixty percent and fifty percent
of each cycle of selection is so high or
the disease resistant but I have to
admit that the I'm the resistant to buy
three leaf spots still need to be
improved and screen since the screening
techniques and even though I try to
screen in the in actual plant it's it's
do like those marker does come from the
multi trait that you ask cannot directly
use for the genomic selected a genomic
existed selection right now it's doing
it for its you need to be validating a
bit and lastly for silicon amendment we
cannot infer in the greenhouse result to
the few results so that might be the
future research again lastly I cannot
stand here and live in America for five
years without the financial funding from
the promotes the development and
promotion of Science and Technology from
Thailand and also I cannot be here and
make sense of my research without my my
committee members don't fine Gary Brooks
Tommy neo Max and also my like I cannot
plant odd of those like four five
hundred of those plants in the few every
year without a hill top of the forest
group Julie Hanson and Jamie Crawford
Brian Crawford and thanks to the member
group in
Gary's left or helping me with the
deceit part and also the plant material
and the genotype data from my castle and
all of my sip by sip friends that I
cannot have out of this idea by just
sitting by myself I got lots of ideas
from from you all so thank you so much
for having me here and welcome for any
questions and if you want to have any
comments very welcome to email me if I -
thank you so much how expensive is the
silicon it madman seems like that might
be an additional objection honest how
expensive is silicon you know I don't I
didn't follow those and you know there's
different ways of adding it and one way
is actually using rice balls for apps
price calls so I think the ideal is to
use these the where where are silicon
already degree that's a waste stream
thank you
if there were any additional questions
for you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu